hi everyone welcome to the homeroom live
stream sal khan here uh very exciting
guest today we're going to have ivec
murthy former surgeon general of the
united states we're obviously there's a
lot of things to talk about
health and mental health related right
now in the world for better for worse
before we get into that i will give my
standard announcements first of all a
reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization we can only
exist through donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about going to khan
academy.org
donate and as we saw several guests ago
with the professor from yale by donating
to khan academy not only will you be
helping many people but you yourself
will become a happier person that's what
research tells us
i also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations that have
stepped up and i'm i'm guessing they're
now happier organizations because they
have stepped up to support khan academy
especially during covid when we were
already running a deficit and our
deficits grew and we continue to run
deficits for 2021. so special thanks to
bank for america google.org at t fastly
novartis and the many many other
supporters of khan academy
last announcement just a reminder that
you can get a version of what you're
hearing right now as a podcast homeroom
with sal the podcast wherever you get
podcasts
now with that i'm excited to go into our
conversation we have vivek murthy the
former surgeon general and now author of
together the healing power of human
connection in a sometimes lonely world
vivec thanks for joining us
hey sal it's great to join you how are
you today
i'm i'm doing all right i mean there's
so much i want to talk to you about
maybe the first thing i mean
just the the role surgeon general i
remember when i was a kid and i remember
that that's what you see everett coop
was the surgeon general and he had the
whole you know no smoking campaign which
was great but i was like is he a surgeon
or is he a general or is he neither
so explain explain to folks what the
surgeon general is and why is that why
is it called surgeon general
well it's a great question so the
surgeon general is
is an individual in the u.s government
who has two roles one is to
number one provide the public with the
best information on health so people can
make good decisions for their families
and the other role is to lead the one of
the uniformed services in the u.s
government called the u.s public health
service commission corps and this is a
group of about 6 600 uniformed officers
doctors nurses physical therapists
and public health engineers and others
who each and every day are working in
federal agencies to strengthen public
health and also deployed in times of
emergency to help with tornadoes in the
aftermath of hurricanes we sent them to
liberia to help with the ebola outbreak
uh you know in a few years back and
together you know the surgeon general
manages these these two responsibilities
but it's because of the role
leading the commission core one of our
uniform services that is actually why
the surgeon general wears a uniform and
lastly i'll tell you that the surgeon
channel is actually not a
general in their rank in in terms of
rank uh because the the public health
service commission corps follows the
navy rank system so then surgeon general
is actually a three-star admiral as
opposed to uh you know uh a general per
se
but they don't call the surgeon admiral
but they don't call the surgeon atom and
it turns out that you don't have to be a
surgeon to be the surgeon general
that in fact most of the recent surgeons
general including myself um have been
either internal medicine doctors or
family medicine doctors there have been
surgeons dr carmona who is a george w
bush's surgeon general was a trauma
surgeon siever coop i was a pediatric
surgeon
so so you know with your
former role as surgeon general and now
this book that you're writing together
and it seems like this touches on you
know kind of social emotional well-being
although i'll let you describe it i'm
sure you can do a better job i mean it
seems like one of your focus areas
really has been you know not just on the
traditional physical health side of
things as surgeon general but also in
the mental i mean well actually i don't
want to speak for you what what what
have been your priorities when you were
surgeon general and now what type of
change or information are you trying to
get out there
well you know when i was a surgeon
general style i began my time in office
with a listening tour where i just spent
time traveling around the country asking
people how i could help and the issues
that i heard
from them were consistent with what we
were hearing and seeing a lot later what
i was seeing in the hospital as a doctor
which is that the fundamental problem
that we have with the opioid epidemic
was affecting communities all across the
country the emerging challenge with
e-cigarettes at that time was also
presenting a great challenge in terms of
you know clawing back in fact some of
the progress we had made on
tobacco and smoking and so i focus a lot
on those but the issue around mental
health and particularly around
loneliness and social connection
um came about in part because of these
early conversations and because i
realized that
behind so many of the stories i was
hearing stories around chronic illness
around depression around addiction were
these threads of loneliness where people
would often say to me you know i feel i
have to carry all these burdens in my
life by myself or i feel if i
disappear tomorrow nobody would even
care they wouldn't even notice
people felt invisible and it wasn't just
uh the people we stereotypically think
of as lonely uh perhaps the older
individual who's living at home by
themselves but i was hearing this from
college students now who were you know
surrounded by thousands of other
students on campus but still felt
profoundly alone i was hearing this from
moms and dads in neighborhoods where
they were you know connected to the
school connected to their neighbors but
still
didn't quite feel like there was anybody
that they could truly confide in anyone
who truly got them and understood them
and so on it went whereas whether i was
talking to ceos or nurses and doctors or
even members of congress themselves i
came to realize that loneliness and this
feeling of being isolated is
extraordinarily common and it turns out
it has profound impacts and implications
for our physical and mental health
that's fascinating and i want to
encourage everyone watching put your
questions on facebook or youtube we'll
i'll surface as many of them as we can
to dr murthy uh but
you know on this this question of
loneliness you know we've had other
guests who've talked about trends social
media making at least young people feel
more anxious or in many cases depressed
is this in your mind a new phenomenon or
has it always been there and we're just
finally unpacking it
just loneliness phenomena especially
well loneliness has been with us for
ages
for centuries and i mean interestingly
if you look back in the literature at
least in western culture shakespeare was
actually one of the first people to
actually talk explicitly about
loneliness in his work or to reference
it
but people have been feeling lonely for
thousands of years
but there are a couple things that are
different now i think one is that um
we unlike you know times in past where
we tended to live in the place same
place that we grew up where we tended to
have generations upon generations living
in close proximity and often living in
the same household
we are living in a very different
society now one that we is relatively
new in the history of civilization where
we are more mobile where we don't
necessarily live
in extended family networks and the
overlay of technology on that has been a
mixed blessing
while it allows us to connect deeply
with people and just stay in touch with
people we may not otherwise and i'll be
allowed to see as easily we also find
that the way in which we're using
technology often displaces our in-person
connection or dilutes our in-person
conversations as we bring our devices
for example to the dinner table or we
allow ourselves to be on them when we're
catching up with friends
and then finally there's one last piece
here that i worry about sal which is i
think there's an element around how
our current
culture
augmented by technology but independent
of that how it actually contributes to
people's sense of self and to their own
well-being and what i worry about sal is
i think that for many of uh young for
many of our young people in particular
but for really for all of us what our
culture tells us is that we have meaning
we have worth as human beings if we're
successful and we're successful if we
can acquire one of three things
wealth
power or fame
and if we acquire those then we we're
held up as success stories and those are
the people we read about in the paper
those are the people whose biographies
you know are lauded those are the people
who are seen as as heroes but the
message that we send to everyone in
society is that if you're not wealthy
powerful
or famous that you are not as worthy and
that is a fundamental problem because i
think our fundamental worth is human
beings
it's not extrinsic it's intrinsic it
comes from our ability to give and to
receive love compassion and kindness and
that's something we're born with
something i see my four-year-old and my
two-year-old
doing each and every day because that's
what kids do that's how we're born into
the world but but we forget it other
things that layered on top of it we come
to believe that if we're kind we'll get
taken advantage of that the world's a
harsh place and that we need to pursue
these other objectives uh like work
wealth and power to have uh to have
meaning and that's a challenge that's a
particular feature of modern society
and is there anything we can do about it
i mean you know we could we can hope uh
that
you know people somehow start profiling
folks who have really content family
lives and all of that but i don't think
you know tmz is about to change or
people magazine is about to change their
their coverage look at this really
content father of four you know you've
never heard of him but he's very happy
um
how how how do we how do we change this
i mean if you can't change culture are
there tools that we can do
uh to to
make it to mitigate the negative impacts
well this is what what i actually found
very encouraging about this topic cell
is that you might think loneliness hmm
that sounds kind of depressing it turns
out though that the reason i think this
is a profoundly inspiring and hopeful
area is because the opposite of
loneliness which is social connection is
something that we are hardwired to
pursue and to build into our lives we
feel better frankly when we're together
we feel safer when we're together it
doesn't mean we're all extroverts but
what it means is that we all need some
degree of social connection we're better
off for and because we are hardwired in
that way it turns out that even a little
bit of meaningful social interaction can
actually make us feel profoundly better
for a long period of time so just think
for a moment about the last time perhaps
you were in the grocery store or in a a
coffee shop and you said
uh pass on a kind word to the person at
the cash register or when they actually
asked how you were doing and then pause
to listen uh to what the answer was
you know those are moments which make us
feel good because they make us feel seen
and heard and they can laugh that
feeling of of feeling seen and heard can
last with us for hours similarly when
you have a a friend who calls let's say
unexpectedly get a call from your best
friend and you have a five or ten minute
conversation that can lead you feeling
great for for a long period of time so
the way we rebuild connected lives the
way we
re-center ourselves around a culture
that recognizes our worth is intrinsic
and grounded and our ability to give and
receive love is we do that by
by leading by example we do that by uh
allowing ourselves to in small ways
initially reach out
to people and enjoy the fruits of human
connection and here's some simple ways
we can do it so like first for example
we can keep 15 minutes a day aside to to
reach out to and connect with people we
care about could be a phone call or a
video conference call it could be
writing to somebody that we love saying
hey i'm just thinking of you and i want
to know how you are second thing we can
do is we can make the time we have with
people really count and we can by
improving the quality of it and the way
we do that most readily is by
eliminating distraction when we're
talking to others that's our cell phone
that's our computer if we have if we
have a tendency to check email or the
news while we're on the phone and the
third thing we can do is seek each other
out looking to serve one another it
turns out silent from ourselves to the
other person and we also
reinforce to ourselves and remind
ourselves that we have value to bring to
the world and this is so important sal
because when people become lonely for a
long period of time what happens is they
lose faith that they actually have any
value to bring to the world they start
to feel that they're lonely because
they're not likable and they also find
that their focus ends up being
excessively on themselves because
they're worried fundamentally about
safety which is what we all worry about
unconsciously when we're lonely
yeah no that makes a ton of sense and i
mean there's two things that i just
heard because when you kind of reach out
to someone and especially show gratitude
towards them and this go this gels with
our conversation we had a a couple of
days ago actually last week about you
know the science of how to be a happy
person you know not only does you do you
show that person that you see them you
appreciate them they feel less lonely
they feel more safe but it's also
there's good research that makes you
happier when you show that gratitude
towards other people you know question
for you
i mean you are very i'm assuming um you
know you you are you are accomplished in
all of the very traditional ways that we
just mentioned that we shouldn't
highlight people but you are
accomplished in those ways um
what what do you do to you know not lose
your balance uh you know i'm sure when
you were part of the administration you
saw a lot of you know classically type a
people who are work work work work
probably not taking the 15 minutes to
kind of call up their cousin and say hey
how are you doing um
what do you do and how do you coach
people to try to balance things a little
bit more
well it's a great question sal and let
me tell you that i
i stand you know here before you as
somebody who's not done it well for much
of my life and in fact one of my
one of my motivations to
to work on this subject area one of the
reasons i was compelled uh to go into it
is because i myself was experiencing a
deep well of loneliness uh and it was
very painful and i felt that
not only during childhood which was a
real a challenge for me in elementary
school but even during adulthood when i
was surgeon general and actually in the
few years that followed it and i what i
realized i had done so is i had always
prioritized and cared about the people
in my life i would they were always you
know from a stated perspective my my top
concerns
but the way i was actually living my
lifestyle was not consistent with those
priorities right so there was a gap
between my stated priorities my live
priorities work was actually
my top priority and i came out of my
time in government after serving a
surgeon general for a few years what i
realized
is that in an effort to
focus wholly on work thinking hey i
don't know how much time i have in
office i want to get as much done as i
can
and you know contribute as much as i can
to public health
i made a critical mistake which is that
i assumed that i would be
better able to do that if i gave all of
my time including that time that i spent
with family and with friends and it
turned out that hurt me like in the long
run it probably reduced
how much i could actually give to the
job because it meant that i was cutting
myself off from one of the most
important sources of fuel that we have
in our lives and that is our
relationships with one another so here's
what i do now
now
when a friend calls
i pick up the phone even if it's just
for 10 seconds to say hey can i call you
later
because just hearing their voice
is powerful and it's much more powerful
than declining the call and then sending
them a text later saying hey can i call
you back the second thing that i do is i
create space in my life now that is free
from distraction and technology often
that's uh in dinner time with the family
and bedtime when i'm you know me and my
wife are putting our two children into
bed but it's time where we're just
focused on on each other and the third
thing that i'll mention to you is
something that i formed in my life
called the moai
and moai is something i write about in
the book it's a japanese
concept actually that began in okinawa
many many generations ago but the idea
is that they would take a group of young
children put them together and say
now you are a group your moi and you are
responsible for each other you have to
look out for each other and so they were
making an explicit commitment to one
another to be there for for each other
and what i realized in 2018 when i was
at a fellowship retreat with two close
friends who i loved dearly but rarely
ever see is i realized that as lonely as
we were all feeling that we would not
end up
truly reconnecting the way that we
needed unless we made an explicit
commitment so we said to each other why
don't we form a moai and we the
commitments we'll make is once a month
will video conference with each other
we'll make it a point to be real with
one another to talk about the stuff that
matters especially the things that we
don't talk about often with our friends
our relationships our finances and our
health and we also made it a point to
say if something comes up in between
those calls we're going to reach out to
each other we're going to have a text
thread and we'll just ping each other
and we can just get on the phone for
five minutes you know to talk through a
difficult situation we'll do that but
we'll make a commitment to be there for
one another and in the last two years
cell that moai has changed my life it
has been an incredible uh incredibly
important anchor uh for me and my two
mawai brothers sunny and dave we start
each other through so many challenges
over the last few years it wasn't that
we weren't friends before that but the
different cell was in taking these
implicit commitments around friendship
making and making them explicit and that
made all the difference
i love that i'm i mean i think i'm gonna
start i'm not joking i think i'm already
making the list of who are the two or
three people i need to join my moai
because you know i'll share on my my own
side you know i couldn't agree with you
more about the you know this this
delusion that that many folks have that
you know if you're already working 40
hours that you're going to be able to be
able to do your job that much better if
you go to 50 60 70 80 hours uh it's just
going to deplete you i remember the
first
job i had out of business school i was
at a hedge fund and i was ready to you
know i thought i would have to work
seven or 80 hours and my
my boss it was only a two-person firm he
said sal our job is to make good
decisions not a bunch of bad decisions
so go home don't think about work
connect with your family and this is
before you know i had just gotten
married uh i didn't have kids at the
time but that's what gave me the time
and space to actually tutor nadia and
that led to all of khan academy but more
importantly it actually did balance me
out and so i never forgot what dan dan
wool it was called wool capital did then
and then i would say about uh five years
ago
you know various stresses just started
to really get to me and i started you
know i started getting claustrophobic in
planes i started and and that's when i
started you know just going down a
similar journey although i'm learning a
lot from your journey of investing you
know that's when i started meditating
regularly that's been transformational
for me um
and i didn't do a moa i think i still
need a moai but uh last year i started
getting a group of a broader friend
circle of friends uh we have a it used
to be we used to meet in the park but
now we meet over over video conference
every week uh where we discuss things
about life you know so there'll be a
topic around you know parenting or tough
love or perception versus reality but
we'll dig into what you know what makes
us tick and they're these you know these
double or triple click conversations
versus what you normally have at a
gathering but i really like the moai
concept with like a smaller group that
you really are
family in the best sense of the word
uh yeah because i'll tell you what
really makes a difference here like in
whether people feel lonely or connected
is really the quality of those
connections and the thing is all of us
regardless of where we grew up what
culture we're in or how old we are we
all have three core needs we want to be
seen and understood for who we are we
want to know that we matter and we want
to be loved right that is true of all of
us and the thing is when you can be in a
relationship with someone a friendship a
romantic relationship where you feel
like you can show up as who you are
where you can don't you don't have to
put on errors you can truly be yourself
that's extraordinarily powerful and you
know one of the great ways um that we
that we can actually
create and experience that kind of
connection is actually by listening and
i mentioned this because so much of our
our emphasis in modern day society is on
action right we have a friend who has a
problem we're thinking okay boom how can
i fix it um we've got somebody else
who's not even a friend a stranger you
know who raises a concern or says
something wrong we want to know okay how
can we correct them how can we get them
the right answer we're very action
oriented but in that sometimes what gets
lost is the power of listening and when
we're able to be fully present with
someone when we're able to give them the
gift of our full attention
when they're able to then share and be
open uh with us
that's an extraordinarily powerful
experience and what we tell somebody
when we listen deeply to them is we tell
them
i see you i understand you you matter
and you are loved
and that's why listening is one of the
most powerful forces we have in forging
strong connection
no i love that it's it's it's super
super powerful and you're exactly right
you're exactly right it doesn't seem
like a action in the traditional sense
but it actually often times leads to a
much deeper relationship than any form
of action and actually you know better
outcomes there's a ton of questions i've
been i've been monopolizing you with all
of mine and i have many more but
obviously as former surgeon general
we're in the middle of a pandemic i
think everyone is super well versed you
know we had dr fauci on here on you know
when we might get a vaccine and the
various therapies so you know i think
folks know about that although i'm
curious if you have any perspectives
that you haven't heard but you know
there's a question here from facebook uh
for christopher mcdade with this
pandemic it's affected a lot of people's
mental health how would you recommend
dealing with this now that we are
isolating ourselves it goes back to the
everything we've been talking about
loneliness is one thing but also
depression and other issues can be
exacerbated what are your views there
well first of all i want to thank i
thank him for his question i mean that's
absolutely right i think many people are
struggling more during this pandemic you
know keep in mind human connection is
healing and at a time of great stress
what we typically do is we seek out more
connection we pick up the phone and call
a friend we go visit someone we care
about and the fact that we can't do that
now i think has exacerbated that stress
it's why you see
a high levels of depression and anxiety
is why you see actually uh
opioid overdoses and alcohol use also on
the rise
but i do think that in this in this
moment we can actually find healing once
again in social connection we just have
to look for it in a slightly different
way so even though we can't for example
go and visit a friend or get together
you know for dinner at a crowded
restaurant the same way we used to we
can actually see friends in
in in safe ways outside for example if
we're getting together and we're mass
and we're distance from our friends and
we're outdoors you know we can create
safe spaces to interact with one another
the other thing we can do
is to keep in mind uh some of these
ideas that sell and i were talking about
earlier around 15 minutes a day keeping
that for to interact with and to reach
out to people you care about making sure
you make that quality of the time count
by eliminating distraction looking for
ways to help people in your network
whether that's a neighbor who might be
struggling because of the you know
they're worried to go to the grocery
store or co-worker who might be having a
hard time teleworking and homeschooling
their child and maybe you just dropping
off some food will make all the
difference these are small but powerful
ways to serve that can actually help
boost our mood as well as strengthen our
connection
so the last thing i'll just mention here
because because it's counterintuitive is
actually the importance of solitude and
you might think gosh if you're looking
for human connection why is solitude
important isn't that the opposite isn't
that being alone well solitude is about
being physically alone but it's actually
a state of of calm
aloneness of joyful aloneness and it's
very different from loneliness which is
a subjective state where i feel pained
about my lack of connection and i feel
the connections i need are greater than
the connections i have and the reason we
all need some solitude in our lives the
reason we have to actually recapture our
ability to be comfortable being alone
for some periods of time is because it
is in those moments of solitude that we
allow the noise around us to settle it's
when we re-center and re-ground
ourselves it's when we reflect
and when we allow ourselves to just be
in a world that is constantly moving
faster and faster and when we can
approach other people from a place of
being more grounded and more centered
we're more able to listen deeply to them
we're more able to be present ourselves
and to share ourselves rather than
constantly worrying about what the other
person is saying you know i say this
knowing that for many people that
finding an hour or two to meditate every
day for example might be way too much
time but solitude can come in many
shapes and forms and sizes it can look
like meditation it can look like just
time where you're sitting on your front
porch and letting the breeze blow
against your face it could be a walk in
nature it could be time and prayer it
could be time spent listening to music
that that soothes you
but how whatever it is and for however
long it is we need those times of
solitude you know i'll leave you with
this wisdom from my nephrology professor
in in medical school this is uh one of
my dearest you know mentors her name is
dr peggy bia and you know when i used to
think i'm too busy you know to create
time for solitude in my life i would
think of her because she was a busy mom
teacher doctor and hospital
administrator but what she would do even
though she didn't have much in the way
of time
was recognizing how important those
moments of solitude were when whenever
she was about to walk into a patient's
room she would go to this thing to wash
her hands and for 20 seconds she would
just allow that warm water to run over
her hands
and she would take a deep breath
and she would remember what she had to
be grateful for that day
maybe it was the hug that her kids gave
her when she was leaving the house maybe
it was a medical student for whom an
idea finally clicked when she was
teaching him that morning maybe it was
the opportunity to participate in the
care of the patient whose room she was
about to walk into
and then taking another deep breath she
would turn the water off dry her hands
and walk into that patient's room
feeling more grounded more centered more
clear about who she wanted to be uh than
before
and that is the power of 20 seconds of
solitude and we all have 20 seconds in
our life but it's important for us just
to remember that power of that solitude
and moments like this when the world is
turning around so fast when there's so
much uncertainty we need to anchor
ourselves and moments of solitude our
relationships with one another are some
of our most powerful anchors
vivek i gotta tell you
you have a future in guided meditation
like i could just take snippets of
what you just said
and i was feeling it i'm not kidding i'm
not trying to i i think there's there's
something very powerful and even just
your answer itself about you're right
you know i i felt that warm water over
my hands and i was like yes i have to
feel the gratitude uh but but you're so
right and it i don't know it appeals so
you know a lot of people think that i'm
extroverted because i i can sometimes
appear but i'm very much an introvert
and you know what the
the notion is where you get your energy
and i need that solitude but you're
exactly right solitude versus loneliness
are are not
are are not the same thing you could be
lonely in a in a crowd as you said on a
college campus in a room at a party you
can feel very lonely in fact that's
often when i feel the loneliness
the the most lonely uh versus uh when
you know i'm alone or when i'm with a
very small group of folks but it's a
super powerful idea
you know just one more question i know
we're limited on time there's so much to
talk about here facebook uh michael
graves how profoundly does
does rejection in a general sense affect
one's loneliness slash depression is
there a way to mitigate the feeling
well i think rejection is so
powerful and so damaging because it gets
at the core of whether we have worth as
human beings when we feel rejected what
we're hearing from someone else
is that you don't have value
that you're not worthy
and this is especially challenging for
for young people whose identity is
developing now this doesn't mean that we
uh you know can't go through life and
figure out how to deal with
disappointment right but there's a
difference between
disappointment and feeling rejected
right disappointment is you know i
wanted something to work out in a
certain way and it didn't
feeling rejected is failing gosh i'm not
worthy i'm not valuable uh that's what
you know the situation is telling me and
we i think can raise our children
to deal with disappointment
but what we have to do what's so
important for all of us whether we're
talking about kids or adults is to know
where our worth fundamentally comes from
because that should be a deep root uh
that
we cultivate and build and nurture over
the course of our lives it should be a
route that's that that's not shaken you
know by circumstance and we all have
challenges like i i struggle with my own
self-worth you know a lot and have over
many years it's a constant effort for me
to remind myself you know during low
points in my life where my value truly
comes from but this is actually where
friendship is so important
because when i was in college and i
asked uh
i asked somebody actually going on a
college classmates from one of these
late night philosophical conversations
that you tend to have in college i said
hey what do you think a friend is
and he thought pause for a moment he
said a friend is someone who reminds you
of who you are when you forget
and i've always remembered that
definition over the years that a friend
is someone who reminds you of who you
are when you forget because we all need
mirrors like that people who can show us
not just who we think we are but who we
truly are who can remind us
of what we bring to the world that's so
special maybe it's our humor maybe it's
our insight maybe it's our compassion or
our kindness
maybe it's all of those things but we
need those reminders you know i'll just
say and you know that this whole topic
that we've been discussing
the subject around connection and mental
health and loneliness
this whole book you know that i wrote on
the subject that while ostensibly this
is about the topic of connection
what it's truly about and what i came to
realize toward the end of this writing
is it's really about love it's about the
question of how do we build lives and
truly a society that's more grounded in
human connection but really in love
because the two forces that are
fundamentally
uh you know driving us in our actions
and you can see this on display in the
world our love and fear and the fear
manifests a lot as anger as insecurity
as jealousy as rage but we see the love
manifesting as well as kindness as
compassion as generosity as concern
but all of us
have the ability and the you know the
capacity to be driven by love or fear
and the question that i think about most
often when i look at my own kids and i
think about what the world will look
like for them
is i think that the world would be more
hospitable to them
more encouraging more supportive more
nurturing
if you and i and everyone out there
does what we can to tip the balance in
the world away from fear and toward love
and to do that by the words we choose to
speak
by how we treat other people by the
issues we choose to work on as well as
the topics that we choose to raise our
voice on and stand up for in the public
square
that's fundamentally what this is about
and when i forget you know at times uh
just how powerful that love can be
um what i think about is a this 10
second
exercise
that fred rogers actually
used famous for doing during his talks
and
and if you have 10 seconds i'll just
walk you and our listeners through it
right now if you take your hand
and you just put it on your heart
and you close your eyes
and take a deep breath
and just think about the people in your
life
who have been there for you
during your highs and your lows
think about the people
who have supported you
who've taken care of you who have
listened to you
who have understood you
even at times when
you weren't sure if you were worthy
of friendship than love
think about the people you turn to in
moments of pain
and in moments of joy
and feel their love
just washing over you
filling you with peace
filling you with happiness
filling you with joy
and open your eyes
what you felt in those 10 seconds
that was the power of love
and that love is most directly
experienced through our relationships
with other people
and as a doctor who has written
prescriptions for many many medicines
over the years some incredibly powerful
ones that are the result of amazing
science
i will tell you that there is no force
more powerful
there is no medicine that is more
healing
than love
and we all have the ability
to heal because we all have the ability
to love you don't need an md or an rn
behind your name
in order to participate in that healing
process that i think is at the heart
of what we need to do right now to help
strengthen our families
our communities and ultimately our world
no well well thank you for i mean that
was incredibly powerful i i don't want
to ruin what you just said i mean you
should just drop the mic at that point
because um
there's so much in there but i think
what's powerful about what you just said
and even the exercise
is you know you'll hear even in you know
cheesy movies you know love is the what
runs the universe or whatever but you're
like what do they really mean but i
think your definition of it is a very
tangible one and it actually was a bit
of an aha that you're really you're you
are right at the end of the day almost
every action is really driven by love
every thought is really driven by either
love or fear and that you know even when
you said that i started thinking about
some of my own thoughts or my own
actions and immediately i started being
able to classify them no that's a fear
one that's a loved one
and maybe that fear one i should do
something different because that's not a
great motivation uh but no what you're
saying is so powerful i mean i think you
know
maybe you know the the the you should be
the the the meditation general or
something like that
and
uh maybe a future administration they
will um introduce some type of
mindfulness for the country because
there's i'm not joking i wasn't kidding
what you know even that last exercise
you're really good at this um i mean i
think and i think you're good at it
because it comes from a place of genuine
authenticity and love which is a very
very powerful thing uh so you know vivek
thanks so much i know we're all out of
time we went actually way over time this
was really powerful but thanks so much
for this and i encourage everyone to
check out together um and you know just
try to figure out ways to lead a
healthier more robust you know together
less lonely life
well thanks so much sal it was so nice
to be with you and uh and thanks for
your interest in this subject and for
everything you're doing to help
support families during this time i must
tell you and i want to encourage all of
your your listeners to support uh khan
academy and to contribute what you can
and you know i'm a beneficiary uh myself
because my two kids they love khan
academy especially khan academy kids and
they're they're constantly asking if
they can be on it so you've provided a
reward for a kid so now if we wanted to
brush their teeth or take a bath and we
say okay you can watch khan academy kids
for a few minutes if you brush your
teeth so thank you sal for the parenting
help
good good good good to hear that no
thank you so much
of course take care then be well
see you
well thanks everyone for joining um yeah
that was a great conversation and i i
wasn't joking uh with with uh vivek that
he should do some whatever you want to
call him meditations or guided
whatever but i thought not only not only
did he have some really good insights
about i think a very important issue
that goes way overlooked for most of us
uh but also you know very tangible ways
of of dealing of of kind of of working
through it uh so thanks for joining uh
the next of our live stream is going to
be we're going to have not as good of a
guest it's going to be me
and then i'm going to
you can ask me anything so see you
tomorrow at noon pacific time talk to
you later
you